hi that's a great outfit
oh you look great well thank you
falaque i really appreciate that um
how are you guys liking you know
being on this hit show about something
so meaningful
love and you know it feels so
timeless but also so modern in the
themes that you guys are discussing on
the show
i'm so proud of this show i i had one
show with mike and molly and that was a
gift and life-changing and this one just
this one just feels right because
without preaching it's just a great
example of
love and it it's it's an example of if
you're lucky enough to find that person
to walk through this life with
then you win that's that's what the
world is about if at the end of the day
you can reach over and there's a hand to
hold
you're ahead of the game and uh and i
love how different we are because
it does you know the more we find out
about our differences the more we find
out we're the same
and uh there's just a lovely connection
and and what's fun about becoming a
couple is and i think where a lot of
comedy is you have to blend the families
and
we all know that's not an easy ride
sometimes and i think that makes for
good humor
and i think it's identifiable to
everybody felake
do you think that the show really
brings home the opposite's attract and
you find this common ground which
my goodness is so thematic of our world
yeah i like to think of it think of it
as sort of like an
asp like an aspirational um show
uh it's a good reminder that it doesn't
matter where you come from it doesn't
matter what you look like
at the end of the day we all want to be
surrounded by love we all want to be
able to provide for
our loved ones and um and that that is
the most
important thing i think it's very timely
during this um
past few years of anti-immigration
sentiment and uh just just to remind
people that like
immigrants are human beings and we're
coming here to look for a better life
absolutely um i couldn't agree
more uh i do love though
you were born in nigeria yes and
something that you said really spoke to
me and made me
giggle because you said in nigeria
people just say it like it is and in
america we have to put a smile on it
um look in nigeria you have to
understand the climate
there it's it's really hot it's really
fast-paced in lagos where i grew up it's
really fast-paced
um the government doesn't necessarily
look out for you so you're out there
building the roads yourself
um connecting your electric power lines
yourself like so you you just have to
you have to be really really
straight to the point and communicate as
efficiently
and effectively as possible so whenever
i need like a
critique or feedback on something i just
call my brothers at home and they're
like
uh no that's stupid uh yeah that's good
and they get straight to the point we
have a conversation in like less than
three minutes
i i think i you know i'm someone who
flowers a lot of things up i'm very
long-winded i don't know how to edit
um i have so much to learn every day i'm
just a student if you won't be offended
we can totally work on it
all right good i just yeah i think i
think i could use some falake in my life
when you came to america you played
basketball right
i did uh i i moved i was in new york for
the first 10 years and i went to the
city college of new york where i studied
theater
and um for my last two years of college
i got on the basketball team the beavers
and i never played before
i knew the rules from playing
playstation with my brothers
but uh the team was so desperate i i was
able to get him
and i was i was a starter by the second
year you're also like into martial arts
yeah i um i always felt like i needed
needed to prepare for the apocalypse
so i uh started taking israeli martial
arts
it's called krav maga when i moved to
l.a
and it's pretty badass you know it
started to scare me for a while
because it gave me a lot of confidence
but then the
the moves are so precise
they're they're so precise and lethal so
i
started getting scared of actually
getting in a fight so i don't know if
that's that's a good thing or a bad
thing but
yeah i studied crab louie
oh i did too billy i was really excited
to talk to you about something
which is that you are an
awesome vet of stand-up comedy
well i don't know if i'm awesome but i
did it for a long time
you really did you you made that round
you were
traveling the country you know 250 days
out of the year
tell me about those days well i i
started in standup you know my dad
was responsible for all that you know he
had richard pryor albums and george
carlin albums and bob newhart albums and
he really introduced me
to to stand up and you know i i realized
pretty quick that i wasn't really going
to college and i wasn't really uh
you know i wasn't really cut out for a
lot so um i loved the idea of words and
making people laugh and
and that just clicked to me and i really
loved it and then sitcoms were big with
him too
and when i was young we would watch the
honeymooners with him and
i would watch you know all of the family
and mash and cheers and
you know the jeffersons and and so i
always dreamt about
doing a sitcom and you know i went out
on the road at about 17 and about 25
years later i was an overnight success
uh well i started an online comedy club
called bananamores
really yes i did because i felt like
uh those rooms are dark and empty right
now and
we need laughter we need comments more
than ever
can i ask you about a story that really
jumped out at me
that the day you met your wife you
saw her three times
i did i saw her three times in the same
day um i saw her at a bank in atlanta
then i was performing at a comedy club
that night and uh
her and her sister just happened to be
there and i spotted her there and then i
went to a jazz club afterwards
and she was there and um i've told the
story a bunch of times but i actually
put it in my act
uh when i saw her in the jazz club i
figured three times in one day you gotta
take a shot
so i ordered a glass of wine i took her
to her table and i said here drink this
and tell i'm
cute and uh which i thought was a pretty
good line until my wife looked at me and
goes i'm gonna need another one
i was like i'm in love that was the end
of it man that must really just mean
something you ran into her three times
in one day i mean that
you know she's been the best thing that
ever happened to me what what she has
she's just stood by me all the way she's
been my rock she's been my good sense my
logical brain and i
i think it takes you a while when you're
married to realize how smart your wife
is
and uh you know if i'm listening to her
chances are i'm not in trouble
so i'm good with that i tend to follow
people who are way smarter wiser
more zen and emotionally capable than me
but at least i'm following
better people um but i know that
you know you were just about to give up
you had been doing stand-up comedy and
you got the call
for mike and i kind of it had just kind
of dried up you know i was in that
period in l.a that everybody goes
through where it was like
just a year or two with no work nothing
on the horizon
and i said i'm going to hang out one
more pilot season and i only got six
auditions in that pilot season then the
last one was mike and molly it was
literally a hail mary into the end zone
and then everything changed
i just happened to be standing in the
right place at the right time
twice so i'm very blessed
very very or maybe it was just all meant
to be and you earned it and you deserve
it
i don't know about that well billy and
felake bob hearts abishola airs monday
nights at 8 30
7 30 central on cbs and cbs all access
[Music]